before I went to college I wish I hugged
my parents and ate a lot more of their
home-cooked meals because you're gonna
get tired of ramen pretty quick first
off don't worry about any of the high
school drama any of the guys in your
high school any of those people because
they're gonna be irrelevant in about two
months the one thing I wish I would have
done in between high school in college
would definitely be fine internships at
least with wine that summer internship
or just internships at all start the
free stuff now so that once you leave
college you've already built your ground
and most jobs actually want to hire you
afterward
I'm from Huy and something that I really
wish I did more before I went to college
was go to the beach I went to school in
Ohio in the middle of nowhere Ohio and
so obviously there are no beaches and
the closest spotty water was the Ohio
River so that's not the best to swim in
learn about sex and drugs because
there's a lot of that in college and
it's better to be educated that way you
know what you're getting yourself into
you're not doing too much too fast
remember to document everything take as
many pictures with your friends as
possible
get that wardrobe right you got to go in
you got a stunt on everyone you got to
be looking good so just kind of like
revitalize that whole wardrobe learn
some respect for deadlines that's just
gonna get you if you don't get it
they're gonna smack you against the wall
do that in learn how to cook you should
thank your teachers
you should also hang out with your
friends as much as possible a lot of
summer you're gonna be able to do it
somehow remember that you signed off on
a student loan because you're gonna
forget and then like five years later
you're gonna get something in the mail
that says you signed a student loan for
like $5,000 totally not speaking for
personal experience read a book that you
actually like want to read for fun
because I don't think you're gonna want
to read a book for fun for the next four
years until college is over my last
summer before College I definitely
regret not actually just chilling like I
was just doing too much and prepared
College and then once it starts that's
it you go through your four years and
then it's like you're in the workforce
and that's their before I went to
college I worked at my summer camp my
sleepaway summer camp and I didn't pack
anything and my mom graciously packed
everything I could have ever needed for
me so my advice is to like go get things
you need for college for yourself so
that when you get there you know what
you have during my last summer before
College I wish I went through a
graduation party I'm 25 and I never had
a big party celebrating me and my
accomplishments so that would have been
dope take risks put yourself in
uncomfortable situations don't do what
everyone's telling you to do because at
least in my life that's when I found the
most interesting thing is that my kind
of discovered who I was don't drink
Jager
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
[Music]